information and then like you keep
contradicting yourself and I think the
reason is is because I am a clash of
cultures so I am very you know obviously
I'm Bangladeshi British Muslim and I
think the modern side is what is me what
I'm fighting against does that make
sense so the more I'm realizing actually
I'm not this model woman is the more
comfortable I'm getting in who I am I
don't I don't think you can really go
back like I I don't think you can really
claim traditional if you're separated
from your like your husband it's no when
I say traditional I say traditionally my
values in my morals not that I'm I'm I'm
gonna stick in a marriage that I'm
unhappy in because I'm a traditional
woman it's more I know what I want for
myself and I know that this right but
like that rhetoric right there that
sounds very modern well can I just say
again all I'm hearing is I I I I I I'm
not and I'm not trying to personalize it
to you it's just that you're speaking
and a lot of the things that have been
said today are eye base and in
relationships in marriage it's about
partnership working together and we're
not nobody's perfect sometimes sometimes
you make mistakes and you have to work
through it and we've I'm not married
I've never been married and I think it's
easy for me to talk on it you know from
my perspective but when you've got
a child involved your feelings involved
you know finances involved whatever it
might be work involved your friends
involved
you you have to kind of peel back on all
of the factors that influence you and
look at the bare bones of the
relationship which is you your child and
your partner and literally Zone in on
that and make that your priority wait
I've got a question I've got a question
quickly just to kind of caveat off it
yeah yeah so on that note you're talking
about I I do would you say that the
Modern Woman is selfish then yes because
it because society allows that to be the
case because it's about what you want is
it what the woman wants that's the case
because I've been very selfless in
relationships I've got nothing back
right exactly yeah but so but if you
have one of yourself no no no but it's
already involved you kind of have to be
selfish I started to cut you off yeah
that's all right selfish like how though
when young kids are involved well like
your kids are your priorities so it's
like regardless of what how anybody
feels like your child is your priority
isn't it in that relationship with two
parents my priority is to take care of
my child yeah yeah but that's that's
being selfless like when you have a kid
it's not supposed to be about you
anymore it's about your kid [ __ ] your
happiness but that's exactly unless
you're in like extenuating circumstances
where you are getting abused or yeah I'm
with you I'm with you if your child if
your child's in danger yeah I I agree
yeah but that's not that's not the
majority of cases it's the child side
danger you need to try work out you know
but that's exactly what like for example
my daughter doesn't know we're separate
my daughter hasn't experienced anything
different when she sees us she sees us
very amicable and she she doesn't know
anything different so when I say a house
no we don't live in the same house okay
but when I say that when I say I'm
putting my daughter first that's the
reason why I'm not chasing another man
or chasing another relationship because
the most beneficial one is me me and her
father but like see you keep kind of
contradicting yourself and you did it
again just here there because you said
your daughter you don't live in the same
house but your daughter doesn't know
anything's up yeah she may not at five
but she will yeah and when and so and so
she might not understand it but you you
can't say that it's like she's not gonna
notice that her dad or her mom isn't in
the home no but I'm not saying there's
my my dad used to work here while my
family were back home my dad wasn't
present in their lives every single day
and I think that's another big
misconception that a parent or a dad has
to be at home every single day it's a
cultural thing is that did it affect you
and not having him there all the time no
no no at all and I love my dad like my
dad was an amazing man an amazing father
figure amazing that's why I can't trash
men because I have so much respect for
me I don't think it would have been
better if your dad was there a bit often
you spent more time
I'm just thinking about Pearl nothing is
that no no yeah my dad my dad was gone
my dad was gone a lot too and I'd say
like it did affect me like I yeah I mean
I I would have been better if he was
there I still love him and I respect him
more than anything but like I I think it
would be dumb to say I didn't want my
dad around more
do you think he would have changed your
perspective on you because you said you
battle being traditional Western do you
think if your dad was there more that
you'd be a lot more traditional than
Western
um
I think the problem with me was when I
went to UNI
trouble the bubble so I think that
bubble protected me for so long and I
wish I stayed in it a bit longer because
the trauma only came when I thought oh
let me experience a bit now can I just
say this do you think your dad being
present in your life when you were
growing up would help you manage your
situation right now with your husband
better because he would have been able
to advise you or even now I don't know
what your relationship is at now but he
would be able to guide you or even have
an impact on you in a way that would
allow you to manage the situation better
I don't know I feel like I'm managing
the situation well compared to what
Society will tell me because there's a
lot of people that will tell me why even
investing any more time or why even
allowing this Dynamics because a lot of
people say OH Close book and rush out
yeah that's why girls give the worst
advice yeah I
I don't say you're managing it well
unless you're still with him can I just
no it's like it's it's not you can't
it's like it's like that's like that's
not getting that's like like failing a
test and seeing you guys no when I say
managing it well I'm saying about I'm
respecting his values or views and where
he is in life I'm respecting that he's
not ready to commit to the marriage and
children yet because he feels like he
can't be that responsible no wait wait
wait before that before
so right I'm so proud of you like we can
all see how much like you love your
daughter how much you're trying to make
this work like because life is hard you
know like no no no no no no she only got
here she only got here because she did
she because before we said yeah that ah
women women said they lack the truth in
it your husband told you the truth
saying that I may potentially want to
step out on you yeah and that's what
started this whole debacle of problems
of relationship so him being honest is
kind of why you're here isn't it
initially it was the my ex cheating that
was the issue but you said you had help
for that trauma you said you had that
trauma no no that's something I've gone
in later like let's say within the last
year because it seems to me like you and
your husband split because of something
that he might do in the future yeah and
that was me looking back at myself
saying I was the fault of that and so
that was me taking it possibility are
you now saying that as a young woman
that traditional is the way to go 100
thank you 100 I'm I will I Believe In
traditional roles I believe I just
believe that this Society doesn't enable
that and a lot of my anger as well even
in my relationship was the fact that I
had to work and I had to do things that
a woman shouldn't necessarily do because
Society now is too expensive can I just
say that Society though can I just say
that traditional women always work they
did yeah
no no no no no you asked your mama how
she worked just because she didn't leave
the house yeah exactly so we're doing
the housework and then more she's
talking about career I'm talking about
Korea but I'm saying that it all depends
on how you see it no 100 right and also
if you and your husband
wouldn't it be better if you both got a
flat with three bedrooms and worked it
out two separately that's the thing
money is the issue so if money wasn't an
issue of course we could have a mansion
and we could no I'm just saying is it is
it there it's live apart than to live
together
yeah uh yes
it's just easier for now because
obviously where we're not fine I'm not
easier I'm talking about cheaper is it
cheaper to live separately or is it
would it be cheaper to live together
it's just not a position we're at now
because we're only I've only just healed
could you just answer that yes or no is
it cheaper to live apart
it's cheaper to live together but
obviously if I'm not like I've only gone
through my counseling and are having to
learn about myself in the last year and
a half that time I was alone if that
makes sense if I'd never done that I
would never have gone through counseling
or learn about myself and what I and
I've learned and I think the thing is I
had an amazing father figure I had an
amazing childhood with my dad and my dad
not being there he was there you know
him not being there for parts isn't
impacted me at all my relationship was
amazing there was other things that
happened when I was a child that made it
more difficult
if that makes sense yeah in me in my
longer lifelong marriage and I think
once I then went counseling for that I
then realized actually there was a lot
of me that had to heal before I even
took that step can I just give you a bit
of advice as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible